[Música]
es momento de hablar de economía hoy con
enfoque de género Daniela Buenos días
para usted Hola Buenos días Ángela hay
un feliz día de la mujer y de la lucha
por los derechos Daniela las cifras de
hoy Tienen que ver con mujeres América
Latina está entre la lista Sí señora
pues el foro económico mundial Calcula
anualmente los avances en la paridad de
género en una escala que va de 0 a 100 y
que mide la distancia que se ha
recorrido para cerrar esa brecha es
decir 100 querría decir que ya se
eliminó por completo y para 2022 entre
146 países esa brecha entre mujeres y
hombres es del 68,1% o sea todavía queda
camino por recorrer según el organismo
esto significa que todavía se necesitan
132 años para alcanzar la paridad total
un cálculo que empeoró con la pandemia
porque venía un poco más de 100 años
dentro de los datos más llamativos que
destaca el foro está que sólo el 37% de
los puestos de Liderazgo están ocupados
por mujeres y que solamente representan
el 22 ciento de la fuerza laboral en lo
que tiene que ver con Inteligencia
artificial que es una tecnología que
promete ser dominante en las próximas
décadas para el mercado laboral ahora
usted hablaba de América Latina Pues hay
una buena noticia Y es que América
Latina y el Caribe ocupa el tercer lugar
entre todas las regiones después de
América del Norte y Europa esto en el
índice general de brecha de género y si
las cosas siguen como van Eso quiere
decir que la región podría cerrar esa
brecha de género en 67 años y no en 132
como el mundo en general y aquí yo
también me sumo a darle la razón porque
América Latina ha sido uno de esos polos
de los últimos años en los que los
derechos de las mujeres se han vuelto
una prioridad y hemos visto grandísimos
avances pero Daniela también hay mucho
camino por recorrer cuando uno habla de
participación política eso hay que
decirlo eso hay que decirlo Aunque
América Latina también se destaca en
este sentido y le voy a decir los
siguientes datos mire la unión
parlamentaria y la ONU mujeres dicen que
solamente 13 países del Mundo cuentan
con al menos el mismo número de mujeres
y hombres en sus gobiernos pero tres de
Ellos están en América Latina Chile
Colombia y Nicaragua es informe también
dice que Albania es el país con más
mujeres en su gabinete tiene 8 de un
total de 12 también dice que 9 países no
tienen ni a una sola mujer entre sus
funcionarios de alto gobierno entre
ellos están por ejemplo Líbano Arabia
Saudita yemen o Siri lanka por mencionar
algunos de ellos dentro de los gobiernos
las mujeres suelen ocupar las carteras
relacionadas con derechos humanos con
igualdad y con asuntos sociales mientras
que su presencia es mucho menos habitual
en los departamentos de Justicia e
interior economía lastimosamente y en
defensa todavía tenemos una
participación muy tímida no Así es
Ángela en Estados Unidos se le puso la
lupa a las redes sociales hay más
noticias económicas Claro que sí se le
ha venido poniendo la lupa durante años
diría yo pero concretamente el día de
hoy pues por un lado la Comisión Federal
de comercio le solicitó a Twitter
particularmente a su dueño elon musk que
entregue información detallada sobre
despidos y otras decisiones comerciales
según el prestigioso diario de Wall
Street journal y es que se estima que ha
recortado más de la mitad de la
plantilla de 7.500 empleados que tenía
antes de adquirir esta red social por
otro lado el gobierno sigue cerrando el
cerco contra tiktok un grupo
bipartidista del senadores presentó un
proyecto de ley que autorizaría al
secretario de comercio a ejercer control
sobre la tecnología que considere que
representa amenazas para la seguridad
nacional y aunque no se dice el nombre
de la red social en el proyecto Sí quedó
claro durante todo el debate que la idea
es permitir que por ejemplo se prohíba
tiktok esta red social de origen chino
en todo el país escuchemos
tiktok me preocupa por varias razones
diferentes una es los datos que tienen
en segundo lugar El algoritmo y el
control de quien tiene el algoritmo En
tercer lugar las operaciones de alta
influencia de la plataforma no es solo
el hecho de que puedes influir en algo
sino que también puedes Apagar algún
mensaje cuando tienes una población tan
grande de usuarios Daniela el dólar
cotiza hoy en el mundo en máximos en
tres semanas Por qué pues Ángela
reacciona de esta manera la divisa
frente a la mayoría de las principales
monedas del mundo luego de que el
presidente de la reserva Federal será un
Powell advirtiera que las tasas de
interés de Estados Unidos podrían
necesitar subir más rápido y más alto de
lo esperado para frenar la inflación
esto se da porque las tasas más altas
que hacen Pues que el dólar sea una
especie de refugio A medida que los
inversionistas buscan seguridad y
estabilidad mientras huyen de esos
mercados bursátiles mundiales que están
bastante volátiles Paola habló ayer ante
el senado y hoy es el turno de la cámara
de representantes en el comité de
servicios financieros pues así reaccionó
ayer el mercado
creo que los mercados se sorprendieron
con los comentarios del presidente de la
Fed especialmente porque insinuó que la
próxima reunión podría generar un
aumento de 50 puntos básicos en lugar de
continuar la serie de aumentos de 25
puntos básicos que el mercado había
incluido en sus expectativas Así que la
actitud agresiva estaba allí de la forma
en que el mercado quería y esperaba pero
la magnitud fue lo que nos tomó por
sorpresa
estas eran las declaraciones que
estábamos esperando desde ayer Así es
bueno yo se lo prometí lo prometí es
deuda bueno cumplimos y para el cierre
otra que es bien polémica Adidas espera
millonarias pérdidas después de su
ruptura con kanye West Sí señora esta
historia Es bien interesante y se
enfrenta a un dilema esta compañía
porque la asociación de marca alemana de
artículos deportivos con el polémico
rapero estadounidense que Data de 2013
dio lugar a la lucrativa línea de
zapatillas pero terminó el año pasado
después de que él fuera señalado de
emitir una serie de mensajes antisemitas
en sus redes sociales Adidas no ha dicho
Cuánto llegó a ganar con esta Alianza
Pero los analistas estiman que gisey
representó hasta el 7% de las ventas
totales en sus mejores años en una
presentación hoy a inversionistas Adidas
dijo que aún está decidiendo qué va a
hacer con todo ese stock de calzado
yeezy sin vender que le quedó el
divorcio con Kenny West efectivamente le
costó unos 630 millones de dólares en
ventas solamente en el cuarto trimestre
de 2022 y esos zapatos le habrían
generado unos ingresos estimados de 1200
millones de dólares este año Entonces si
Adidas decide no venderlos cancelaría el
inventario por completo y eso reduciría
sus ganancias en otros 500 millones de
dólares este año aparte de 200 millones
que ya estima perder en otros costos En
todo caso la empresa dice que esta
ruptura con El rapero y diseñador de
moda podría llevarlo en 2023 a su
primera pérdida anual en tres décadas
difícil decisión muy difícil la verdad
Daniela hasta aquí llegamos con este
primer segmento de economía pero la
espero más adelante para más noticias Sí
señor aquí nos vemos